summer of 1995 was the hottest summer in  year  the single of the season was Seal's kiss  from a rose and Jim Carrey was the  biggest star in Hollywood  if you could would you go down on  yourself I heard Marilyn Manson can do  that people would probably stop  reproducing most people aren't aware of  the exact moment when they lose their  innocence they usually have been slowly  but for me it was all at once CPD is  keeping a close eye on every lead I love  crazy  Casper Tatum was easily the town's  favorite suspect I think I got the hots  for the dead girl's sister Casper Tatum  killed Chrissy and he's gonna pay did  you do it not for me  did you see anything I saw a lot of  things that night  [Music]  our town was put under a dark spell in  the summer of 1995 I was 15 years old  you